you've observed
suffering
darker aspects of human nature in your
own personal life
what has been some of the darkest
moments in your life
darkest times in your life
is there
something
that you went through
and then perhaps you carry it yeah
through your work
yeah
probably one of the darkest moments was
an experience that i had
again in my early 20s
and i was living in southern california
and
i
you know the pacific coast highway that
goes north and south along the beach and
there's that little
uh concrete path that people jog and
ride their bikes and i was riding my
bike on the on the pch
and um i was coming up to a corner on it
and i heard this tremendous crash
and it was really loud and i came across
the corn around the corner
and it wasn't a car accident a car crash
it was a multiple multiple vehicle crash
and what had happened is that um a volvo
had um
hit another car and then when it hit it
it went over the top of the car
and hit a volkswagen van and it peeled
away the top of the volkswagen van when
it hit it and then landed
so three vehicles
and it just happened
and um
lying in the middle of the road
was
a body
decapitated
and there was another
person
from one of the cars lying in the middle
of the road still alive
and then on the hood of the volvo
was this woman who had come through the
windshield
just
a mess blood everywhere
moaning
back and forth
and
a bystander
ran into the middle of the road
and started administering first aid to
the person lying in the road
and um
i stood there watching this scene
and every
fiber of my being
wanted
to run to the woman
on the hood of the volvo
and do something anything right just to
be there and it was obvious to me that
she was she was gonna die
but i felt like at least if i ran there
i could offer some comfort for her last
moment
and right then
the sirens started to blare
and i knew that
there'd be paramedics there within
minutes that that people would come to
help
and i froze
and i was scared
and i didn't do anything
and i watched
while this woman
died
on the hood of the volvo
and that experience
is sort of seared into my consciousness
um the fact that i watched and didn't
act
i i feel is one of the great failures of
my life
that i wasn't able to act in a moment of
need no matter how small
and from that
i made a decision out of that experience
that
if i ever found myself in a situation
where i had the ability to act and i
could act to help another human being in
such need that i would act
that i wouldn't let fear
freeze me instead i would allow that
fear to catalyze me into action
and do something and intervene in
whatever way i could
even if i didn't have the skill set and
in some ways
all of that echoes in your documentaries
you're not going to let fear
stop you from trying to help i think
that experience that that experience of
failure
what i s what i framed as
just human failure on my part um is is
foundational probably for my work like i
don't want that to happen again legs
like like i i don't want to be that
person who watches
i want to do what i can when i can
you